MaMartine Baron, Michel David,
vévéranda S, bonsoir...- Bonsoi.
- - Le ministre des transports a
dédévoilé aujourd'hui la dernièe
momouture de ce troisième lien
enentre Québec et Lévis, projetn
a a parlé en début de l'émissio.
PlPlus modestes, plus petits,
momoins chères.
EnEn vain écouter le ministre
d'd'abord.
FRFRANÇOIS BONNARDEL,
miministre des Transports, Québc
- - L'objectif principal avec
lala livraison du réseau express
dede la capitale et du tunnel
QuQuébec-Lévis, c'était
dede répondre à trois choses :
auaugmenter l'attractivité
dudu traransport collectif, donr
unune option additionnelle pour
lele transport de marchandises,
amaméliorer la fluidité et assur
lala sécurité du réseau.
CÇa veut dire qu'aujourd'hui?
BiBien la mise à jour nous amène
àà dévoiler un projet révisé,
unun projet estimé à 6,5 millias
dede dollars.
- - Martine je vais commencer ac
vovous.
EsEst-ce que ce projet révisé de
trtroisième lien répond aux
bebesoins de la population de
raration- Je pense que l'exercie
d'd'aujourd'hui c'était de rende
cece projet la plus vendable en
cacampagne électorale.
OnOn aura noté que c'est plus
pepetit que ce qu'il y avait sur
lala table avant.
UnUn seul tunnel qui nécessite e
plplus gros tunnelier au monde,a
papaix démesurée.
OnOn l'a comparé au tunnel Louis
HiHippolyte Lafontaine, en ce
sesens, oui il est plus petit.
C'C'est plus pour être capable e
lele vendre en campagne électore
ququi s'en vient dans six mois.
OnOn a noté qu'il y avait un grs
vovolet pédagogique à l'exercice
auaujourd'hui où on nous a dit e
leles liens pour rentrer à Québc
sosont achalandés, ils sont vie.
NoNotez qu'il y a 18 liens pour
rerentrer à Montréal, notez qu'l
y y a cinq liens pour aller à
OtOttawa, et il y en a un sixièe
dadans les cartons.
AÀ Québec il n'y'y a que deux ls
ququi sont côte à côte.
SaSans en prendre un autre.
IlIl n'en demeure pas moins quee
tytype de projet sont tellement
grgros qu'ils sont difficiles à
fafaire atterrir.
OnOn l'a vu aujourd'hui, le maie
dede Québec était plus ambivale,
c'c'est un projet qui reste à
dédéfinir, c'est vrai.
C'C'est vrai qu'on a peu de
dédétails.
ToTout le monde ne rame pas dans
lele même sens.
C'C'est la situation actuelleme.
- - C'est vrai qu'on n'a pas
bebeaucoup de détails concernant
lele futur troisième lien.
AuAucun schéma, il y avait une
phphoto, un dessin, pas
d'd'animatation en 3D.
PaPas de clarification sur le
trtracé précis.
OnOn parle d'un dossier
d'd'affaires, Michchel, qui sern
202025 alors qu'il devrait y avr
unune pelletée de terre avant
auautomne qui s'en vient.
- - On n'en a pas plus aujourd'i
ququ'on avait.
LaLa études...
ququ'on a brandi c'est toujoursa
mmême celle de Monsieur
MaMassicotte qui est propre spae
àà polytechnique qui date de
202016.
DeDe toute manière ça aboutit à
unune conclusion qu'il va y avor
vovous parliez de la dernière
momouture, je ne suis pas
coconvaincu que ce qu'on voit
auaujourd'hui sera ce qu'on voit
apaprès la dernière élection.
QuQu'il faille un troisième lie,
c'c'est pas possible, mais
popourquoi un tunnel plutôt qu'n
popont. Je comprends que les vos
seseront provenant de tunnel
plplutôt que dans un, ça ne chae
rien à l'étalement urbain, le
prproblème demeure entier.
QuQuant aux coûts, ces 6,5
mimilliards, maintenant, on vera
dadans 10 ans.
JeJe pense que le débat ne chane
papas.
CÇa ne change pas de paramètres
avavec ce qu'on nous a présenté
auaujourd'hui.
- - Sur le coup Monsieur
MaMassicotte, disait qu'à son as
c'c'est un prix plancher, ça va
nénécessairement aller plus haut
quque ça.
LeLe Fernandez, avez-vous comprs
leles explications données par e
miministre pour avoir enlevé le
vovolet de transport collectif
dadans les tunnels.
OnOn n'y va par des voies
réréservées seulement en heurese
popointe.
- - C'est ridicule, c'est une
méméthode utilisée depuis des
dédécennies.
CeCe n'est pas du transport, c't
unun transport en ses propres, n
fafait des fois réservées quandn
a a de la congestion.
BéBérégovoy réservées le matin,n
l'l'enlève en après-midi.
C'C'est quand il y a de la
cocongestion, on évite la
cocongestion.
LeLe reste de la journée on
l'l'enlève.
EsEst-ce qu'on n'est entre nous
didit qu'il va y avoir de la
cocongestion dans les tunnels.
EsEst-ce ça le message.
IlIl n'a pas utilisé son dossie,
c'c'est ridicule.
AuAutre chose, cette histoire de
vovoies réservées qu'on peut
memettre ou enlever, c'est un
trtrait de peinture.
EsEst-ce que tout à coup Ottawaa
sese dire, c'est projet de
trtransport en commun, que je
viviens de financer, à mon avisl
n'n'arrive pas à convaincre les
exexperts.
EsEst-ce qu'il arrive à convaine
lala population, est-ce que ça a
pepermettre d'aller chercher un
pepeu d'adhésion avant l'électi.
JeJe n'en sais rien.
MaMais au niveau des experts, il
nene réussit pas.
- - Sur le côté du financement
d'd'Ottawa, on a accepté de
fofournir de l'argent pour le
trtransport collectif.
LeLe Québec revient avec cette
momouture avec seulement des vos
réréservées en heures de pointe,
onon compte toujours sur le
fifinancement de 40 % de la part
d'd'Ottawa.
- - Pour l'instant, le projet
ququand on écoute le ministre sa
prprêt en 2025.
EnEn 2025, c'est à ce moment-là
ququ'on vaqua de déposer le prot
etet de voir si les financements
etet la.
LeLes politiciens peuvent réussr
àà faire rentrer un cercle dans
unun carré.
OnOn verra en cela, mais on n'et
papas là.
JuJuste régler l'enjeu au Québec
çaça va déjà être quelque chose.
JeJe parlais de Monsieur Marchad
tatantôt, du maire de Québec, iy
a a Éric Duhaime aussi qui est
dadans l'équation, s'il se fait
élélire dans des trois
cicirconscriptions de dans la
rérégion de Québec, il va voir n
popont.
LeLe projet ne fait pas
l'l'unanimité, ce n'est pas tout
lele monde qui vont ensemble das
lele même sens.
CÇa fait défaut, il va falloir
quque les gens s'entendent avant
d'd'avoir un projet prêt à être
dédéposé et financé.
- - On nous disait que c'était s
mamal unanime la plus qu'on a
coconcernant le projet, hormis
ququelques exceptions près on
pepense au maire de Québec, qui
n'n'est toujours pas convaincu u
bibien-fondé du projet.
OnOn va l'écouter.
GEGENEVIÈVE GUILBAULT,
vivice-première ministre du Quéc
- - C'est tellement important
d'd'avoir cette vision-là, ne ps
dédévelopper les projets de
trtransport pour une ville, pour
unun secteur, pour un groupe,
avavoir vraiment une très, très
grgrande vision inclusive.
BRBRUNO MARCHAND,
mamaire de Québec
- - Je ne pourrais pas m'attachr
àà un arbre ou quelconque espace
ouou mobilier urbain pour ne pas
quque ça se réalise. Maintenant,
lala ville a un influence.
LaLa ville a une capacité de fae
dedes études, de démontrer
s's'il y a des enjeux,
s's'il y a des problèmes. Qu'es-
cece qu'on peut y faire? Comment
pepeut les contourner? Mais avat
d'd'arriver là, notre objectif
c'c'est d'avoir plus de données,
plplus de faits, plus de
dédémonstrations.
- - Michel qu'est-ce qu'il faut
pepenser de cette relation entre
leles mains de Québec lumière
miministre Guillebaud.
- - Difficile, on l'a vu.
JeJe me souviens quand Monsieur
MaMarchand est élu, Madame
GuGuillebaud était statique, ele
ététait contente de se débarrasr
dede Monsieur Nadon, mais ça n'a
papas été long avec le tramway e
dadans le fond le rapport de foe
enentre la fée, où les tensions
enentre la ville et le
gogouvernement sont sensiblement
leles mêmes qu'elle était avant.
MaMadame Guillebaud, tout le moe
esest d'accord, un instant,
MoMonsieur Marchand n'est pas sl
àà ne pas être d'accord avec ce
prprojet.
AÀ Québec, ce n'est pas si
avavantageux à ce troisième lie.
LeLes gens de e la réussite sont
avavantages à ça, mais qu'est-ce
quque c'est cette histoire, c'et
unun tunnel qui va relier deux
auautoroutes.
PoPour les gens de Québec, je
paparle des Québec, non des
babanlieues, ce n'est pas si
inintéressant que ça.
- - Luc, à six mois des électio,
est-t-ce que le gouvernement
LeLegault peut se permettre
d'd'avoir des relations tendues
avavec le maire de Québec?
- - Et bien oui malheureusement,
ilil a démontré lors de la
papartielle dans Marguerite
ViVictorin, qu'il était en étate
grgrâce.
IlIl n'y a rien qui l'a peint en
ce moment.
EsEst-ce que ça va changer dans
leles six prochains mois, est un
dodossier majeur.
IlIl y a des dossiers majeurs se
sosont produits dans les derniès
sesemaines.
CÇa ne l'a pas touché.
AvAvec la pandémie, ça ne l'a ps
totouché.
IlIl est en état de grâce.
LeLe troisième lien, c'est le
gegenre de projet qui se fait sr
dedeux mandats, peut-être plus.
AÀ la longue, je ne veux pas ête
enen opposition avec le maire de
QuQuébec, et avec l'ensemble des
esespaces Québec.
- - Martin.
- - C'est ce que Monsieur Marchd
a a aussi des intérêts à bien
s's'entendre avec le gouvernemet
dede la 4.
IlIl tient son tramway, il le
popouls caucu caquiste.
IlIl y a Jonatan Julien ququi aé
unun rôle, ça a été difficile.
SiSi le premier ministre a
trtranché, il a dit au calcul de
QuQuébec, on n'y va avec le
trtramway.
PoPourriez-vous garder la paix
popour un moment.
MoMonsieur Marchand il a son
trtramway, il a le feu vert pour
leles appels d'offres, il a
inintérêt à ce que ça se passe
bibien avec le gouvernement-là e
lala CAQ. Il va y avoir une sui,
ilil faut faire attention,
MoMonsieur Marchand, pour ne pas
sese prononcer sur le troisième
lilien et ne pas le biffer, il a
papas dit quelle horreur, mais a
nene répond pas à ses objectifs
d'd'étalement urbain mais il ree
àà définir.
- - Il marchait sur des yeux das
sasa réaction.
OnOn va parler de la pandémie,
ChChristian Dubé est sorti
auaujourd'hui pour parler de la
COCOVID-19, pour la mise en gare
dede la longue fin de semaine de
pepente qui s'en vient.
MAMARC TANGUAY, député, PLQ
LaLaFontaine
- - Il y a un appel à la plus
grgrande prudence qui a été lane
hihier, on pense que c'est
évévidemment la bonne chose
àà faire. Puis écoutons la santé
pupublique.
MAMANON MASSÉ, députée, QS
SaSainte-Marie - Saint-Jacques
- - Où est-il pour encourager
lala population du Québec à dir:
babaissez pas les bras!
MoMon sentiment c'est que,
çaça me donne le sentiment
quque lui a baissé les bras.
JOJOËL ARSENEAU, porte-parole du
PQPQ en matière de santé
- - Le gouvernement justement,
nene veut pas imposer des règles
paparce que c'est impopulaire.
IlIl est allé d'un bout du spece
ouoù il contrôlait nos vies,
àà l'autre bout du spectre où
c'c'est le laisser faire le plus
cocomplet.
CHCHRISTIAN DUBÉ, ministre de la
SaSanté et des Services sociaux
- -  Sont un peu difficiles
àà suivre l'opposition; d'un côé
pependant le dernier bout de la
papandémie ils nous disaient
quque la santé publique devait
êêtre indépendante et ne pas
avavoir d'influence politique.
VoVous avez remarqué que depuis
ququelques mois, la santé publie
prprend les points de presse
seseule, ils nous font
dedes recommandations, alors
ilil faut qu'ils se décident.
- - Martine, il faut penser quoi
dede tout ça, est-ce que le
gogouvernement a lâché cette
susuggestion de la pandémie?
- - Non, parce que c'est le
gogouvernement qui a le dernier
momot.
C'C'est le gouvernement qui
trtranche et qui prend les
dédécisions.
IlIl y a effectivement aucun
apappétit au gouvernement pour
imimposer de nouvelles mesures
SaSanta.
OnOn a été marqué, au gouvernemt
lala CAQ, avec le gouvernement u
etet leur langue du 31 décembre.
OnOn voit ce qui se passe
aiailleurs, et on réalise, on et
rerendu à la sixième vague en dx
anans, ça fait trois vagues par
anannée.
EsEst-ce qu'on va constamment,
vevenir dire que vous ne pouvez
papas l'avoir plus que 10
pepersonnes chez vous... l'autre
fafacteur important, c'est que a
plplupart des gens sont vaccinés
dede deux à trois doses, le danr
d'd'hospitalisation est moins
élélevé.
EfEffectivement, un moment donné
tutu te dis : " apprenez à vivre
avavec le virus ".
C'C'est sûr qu'il y a un test,
teteste pas, parce que les
hohospitalisations augmentent, e
pepersonnel de la santé est
papassablement infecté.
OnOn a envoyé des messages en
coconséquence.
- - Est-ce qu'on a une santé
pupublique indépendante, Michel,
onon entendu le ministre dire :"
vovous y vouliez une santé
pupublique indépendante, vous
l'l'avez ".
EsEst-ce vraiment le cas.
- - Ça dépend toujours du minise
dede la santé, c'est certain qun
didissociant les deux, ne pas vr
lele directeur de la santé
pupublique du côté du ministre,a
dodonne une impression
d'd'indépendance.
IlIl y a des limites.
CÇa ne veut pas dire qu'il faut
ququ'on abandonne le directeur e
lala santé publique.
LeLe Docteur Boileau, on voit
rérégulièrement r répéter ses
coconsignes.
OnOn a l'impression que le
gogouvernement sans laver les
mamains.
- - Depuis des semaines.
- - Depuis des semaines, et je
cocomprends que ce n'est pas trs
popopulaire, et le gouvernement
vovoulait donner le message qu'l
avavait comprit la population.
SaSans revenir à des mesures,
c'c'est de répéter le message.
CeCe n'est pas fini, quand le
prpremier ministre vient nous de
: : " ce n'est pas plus grave
ququ'un rhume ", je commence un
pepeu hors contexte, on a un
miminimum de comme question, on
n'n'a pas COVID D et rhume dansa
mmême phrase.
LeLe premier ministre a mal géré
cecette intervention.
LeLes gens ont compris, c'est
fifini, on fait ce qu'on veut.
CeCe n'est pas la faute de la
sasanté publique, je pense que
LeLegault a continué à prodiguer
seses conseils.
JeJe crois qu'il aurait dû cours
dedes fois de dire que comme le
mamasque, il est clair dans son
esesprit qu'il faut pas enlevere
mamasque.
OnOn va laisser le gouvernement
prprendre officiellement la
dédécision.
- - Effaçait recommandations das
leles prochaines journées.
- - Je pense que tout le monde a
cocompris que le menton va le
gagarder pour un petit moment.
ClClairement, qu'est-ce que penr
dede tout ça.
- - Ce n'est pas une mauvaise
etethnie, en Ontario, il en il a
ququelques semaines, et la
didirection de la santé publique
dede l'Ontario demande fortement
dede ré imposer le masque.
S'S'il y a une mesure fort dans
cecette capacité de vivre avec e
vivirus, c'est le masque et la
vavaccination.
PaPas tout de suite, mais
cecertainement à l'automne, pour
lala quatrième dose, tout est en
cece moment, ça ne pas grand-che
àà faire.
OnOn est à 2004 dans les hôpita.
OnOn est beaucoup plus haut dans
lala pandémie aujourd'hui qu'on
l'l'était.
MaMais en Europe, la sixième vae
a a commencé à descendre, quanda
sese passe en Europe, on sait qe
çaça va se passer si.
ImImposer des déconfinement, des
grgrandes manoeuvres nationalesa
nene fonctionnera pas.
PrPréparons-nous pour l'automne,
ququand Martine et Michelle Gis,
ilil faut que Monsieur Boileau t
plplus de prise, de poids, c'est
popour cet automne.
CeCet automne, il faudra décider
d'd'aller avec la quatrième dose
etet que le gouvernement mette n
popoids derrière.
- - Vous nous amenez à l'automn,
lelequel justement, le parti
coconservateur, le choix du
prprochain chef, cela fait en
seseptembre.
IlIl y a un sondage léger, c'est
didifficile pour Jean Charest fe
a a Pierre Poilièvre.
OnOn peut voir ce résultat, dans
l'l'ensemble des répondants, c't
asassez au coude à coude, mais
ququand on regarde chez les
coconservateurs, Pierre Poiliève
esest loin devant.
QuQuelques secondes chacun, un
pepetit 20 secondes.
LuLuc, qu'est-ce que vous en
pepensez?
- - Je pense que non, même si le
momode électoral au sein du pari
coconservateur, les appuis de
PoPoilièvre sont surtout dans
l'l'Ouest, Jean Charest va aller
chchercher dans les maritimes, u
QuQuébec et en Ontario.
C'C'est ça sa façon de s'en
sosortir.
- - Michel.
- - Le problème M. Charest et qi
esest la seule raison pour
lalaquelle ils auraient pu être
tetentés de choisir Monsieur
ChCharest et qu'il aurait été ms
enen mesure de battre les
lilibéraux.
OrOr, nos données de sondages
momontrent que non, ce n'est pas
lele cas.
MoMonsieur Poilièvre perdrait
pepeut-être un devant les
lilibéraux, mais Charrest encore
momoins.
PoPour la même raison, et peuvet
sese dire que les deux militent
popour Monsieur Poilièvre.
- - Et Martine en quelques
sesecondes.
- - Je faute attendre les débat,
c'c'est là que ça va se jouer.
LuLucas raison, les maritimes, e
QuQuébec, ces deux tiers des
cicirconscriptions au pays.
C'C'est vraiment en Ontario, es-
cece que Monsieur Charrest est